je pensais que que je devais me donner
la possibilité de savoir ce que ce dent
qui m'était donné voulait aller me ou ça
m'emmener et qu'est-ce que je devais
faire
bonsoir alors wonderful c'est extrait
d'un CD qui sort qui est un hommage à
George Gershwin pourquoi Gershwin c'est
parce que vous avez chanté tout de toute
façon vous avez chantez aussi bien du
classique que du jazz etc pourquoi faire
un CD uniquement sur Gershwin parce que
c'est un compositeur génial
[Musique]
magnifique
non c'est vrai alors bon vous avez
commencé effectivement dans le classique
vous avez fait du jazz du negro
spiritual les classiques de Disney aussi
un certain morceau comme celui-là qui a
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
son prince viendra bien et alors
pourquoi vous avez jamais fait de pop
musique parce que finalement vous avez
été élevé on a le même âge vous avez été
élevé avec la motarde avec les suprêmes
les Beatles Lennon Clapton écoutez chez
vous andrix etc qui est qui n'est pas le
frère de Barbara Hendrix ni votre cousin
et pourquoi vous pourquoi vous avez
jamais interprété de la pop
bon je crois que ce n'est pas quelque
chose que je pense que je suis bien pour
bien faire
tu la musique que je fais reste un peu
dans le classique je dis même les
chansons de Disney mais aussi de
Gershwin ça reste dans le jazz plutôt
classique dans ce que je sens capable de
le faire vous auriez pas l'impression si
vous ayez de la pop musique que ça
serait pas bien pour vous non ce n'est
pas ça moi je crois que c'est moi c'est
moi qui n'est pas bien pour la musique
en même temps vous auriez aimé faire un
duo avec Marvin
c'est un disque d'amour en plus les
paroles beaucoup
[Musique]
quand on étudie un petit peu votre vie
Barbara Hendrick son comprendre en fait
pourquoi vous faites tout ça parce que
vous êtes né dans l'arc-en-ciel en 48 à
une époque où on disait qu'il y avait
une ségrégation raciale en fait vous
dites bon on disait ségrégation mais
c'était plutôt l'apartheid on disait
ségrégation par pudeur et alors voilà il
faut se souvenir quand même c'est pas si
vieux que ça quoi c'est il y a quoi 50
ans
les hôpitaux les piscines les écoles
étaient des lieux séparés c'est à dire
qu'il y avait d'un côté les Wright only
et c'était séparé vous étiez élevé
là-dedans faut réfléchir à ça oui je me
souviens aussi que la première fois que
je suis allée en Afrique du Sud pour
l'investiture de Nelson mandala nous
sommes allés au restaurant manger ou là
il avait toujours sa c'est affiche même
que c'était c'était ouvert il avait
cette affiche et que ce qui m'a
transporté vraiment 50 ans
vous dites par exemple dans les garages
on avait le droit de d'acheter de
l'essence mais on n'a pas le droit
d'utiliser les
vous dites je savais que ma vie valait
moins que celle d'une petite blanche de
mon âge on en parlait pas on savait
qu'il y avait des lynchages des
disparitions ça faisait partie comme ça
du l'ambiance de la société américaine
de l'époque quelque chose qui en avait
pensé tous les jours mais on a entendu
pas les parents qui parlaient un peu
Bavois et ils n'ont pas vraiment parlé
ils ont essayé de nous protéger les
enfants mais quand même je crois que les
enfants sont beaucoup de choses que les
parents cachent tout le temps et
des fois un certain peur qui est dans on
n'a pas parlé de parler oui je savais
que si quelque chose m'arrivait il y
aurait personne pour crier c'est injuste
bien sûr mais mes parents et des gens
tout de moi mais pas une justice du pays
non il y a une évolution grâce à des
héros comme Martin Luther King bien
entendu et finalement c'est ça qui
aujourd'hui vous amène à vous occuper
des de l'homme au départ dans votre
jeunesse ou militiez contre la guerre du
Vietnam pour le droit des femmes et puis
un jour vous avez découvert qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui existait
d'ailleurs c'est né quoi en 48
c'est-à-dire 10 jours avant moi
et là vous avez découvert la Déclaration
universelle des droits de l'homme et
vous avez découvert que il existait
enfin quelque chose
qui permettait de globaliser le combat
et de pas uniquement se limiter au droit
de la femme ou
je me trouvais avec tous les combats on
était on avait toujours quelqu'un qui
est en face à qui on devait prendre les
droits pour pour l'obtenir nous-mêmes et
je trouvais que il faut avoir des droits
qui sont pour tout le monde où tout le
monde peut trouver leur place et dans la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme et là c'est là où j'ai trouvé
vous savez ce premier article qui dit
que tous les êtres humains sont nés
égaux en droit et en dignité ils sont
nés avec la raison et la conscience
lorsqu'on portait entre eux dans un
esprit de la faire fraternité et
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il y en a besoin
de ça plus que jamais depuis ces 50 ans
qui est on avait adopté cette
déclaration
dit que il faut
occidentaliser le monde entier que la
civilisation chrétienne est supérieure
la civilisation islamique c'est un c'est
un ignorance totale un manque de
sensibilité inacceptable
alors voilà vous étiez quand même une
nature rebelle quand vous étiez
adolescente à grande gueule
et toujours vous avez refusé d'être la
fille du pasteur parce que votre père
était pasteur méthodiste vous refusez
d'être la fille du pasteur et après vous
études de chimie et de mathématiques à
l'Université du Nebraska contre la vie
de vos parents vous partez étudier la
musique à New York ça c'est vous avez
fait un petit cours d'été à Aspen non
et là voilà vous avez rencontré Jimmy
Thorell et là finalement vous vous
décidez après ça de partir à New York à
la joie school pour étudier le chant oui
mais sans savoir qu'est-ce que
m'attendait je n'avais j'avais aucune
idée de qu'est-ce que c'était la vie ou
une carrière chanteuse d'opéra la
musique classique mais
je pensais que je devais me donner la
possibilité de savoir ce que ce dent qui
m'était donné voulait aller ou ça les
m'emmener et qu'est-ce que je de faire
et j'avais décidé de donner tout pour
apprendre tout ce que je pouvais parce
que pour pas arriver à là je suis
aujourd'hui et de dire à mes enfants
mais vous savez j'aurais pu faire mais
je dis bah peut-être je vais dire à mes
enfants j'avais essayé de faire quelque
chose ça n'a pas marché et c'est pour ça
que je regrets vous êtes lancés dans la
grande aventure pour pas avoir de
regrets aventure parce que si vous
pouvez imaginer que moi je suis arrivée
à New York sans sans rien sans rien
connaître
seulement avec ce don avec mais avec
beaucoup d'espoir même que j'ai beaucoup
de difficultés dans ma vie j'étais
jamais malheureuse j'étais toujours
heureuse de vivre et toujours beaucoup
d'espoir et même même aujourd'hui quand
on a dans ce monde qui est qui est
vraiment plus fou que jamais
je dois garder l'espoir parce que comme
mes enfants je regarde trois points qui
on va pas continuer de faire tous les
contrôles qu'on avait fait jusqu'à
maintenant je sais pas si c'est parce
que vous faites partie de la génération
qui a eu 10 ans 19 20 ans en 68 enfin à
l'époque de cette révolution qui n'a pas
été françaises qui a été mondiale mais
vous êtes devenu une star vous êtes
toujours refusé d'être une diva
vous dites je veux pas coller à l'image
mythique de la diva cultiver la légende
alors qu'à l'école quand vous étiez la
jolie hard School à New York toutes les
filles se voyaient déjà sur scène vous
voyez et vous ça vous a toujours un peu
gavé quoi bon je veux les toujours avec
quelque chose qui était très précieux
c'était moi-même
vous savez quand j'avais
15 ans mes parents étaient très strictes
et je n'avais pas le droit de sortir et
bon on a été assez pauvre je n'avais pas
les vêtements les plus jolis l'école et
il avait une jeune fille qui était une
amie qui avait une vie totalement
différent elle était belle elle avait
des des parents qui
l'avaient laissé faire des fêtes chez
elle et bonne soirée bon je pleurais je
dis mais qu'est-ce que je donnerais pour
être elle et finalement comme je n'avais
rien je n'avais rien j'avais un don
j'avais mon talent j'avais décidé
d'assumer et j'avais des intelligence
voilà c'est tout ce que j'ai qui
m'appartient et bon je ne donne rien et
je crois que c'est la dernière fois de
ma vie que j'étais jalouse de personne
et je crois que les chaussures où je
suis sont les chaussures où je dois être
dans
alors là justement
on vous applaudit mais vous dites j'aime
qu'on m'écoute mais pas pour les
applaudissements pour faire passer la
musique très généreuse alors évidemment
bon ben on le sait et on vous en
félicite et c'est aussi pour ça qu'on
est heureux de vous recevoir vous
profitez de votre notoriété pour pour
développer des actions humanitaires et
vous dites en parlant de la vie on n'est
pas là pour faire un métier gagner de
l'argent et mourir
il faut laisser quelque chose
en Afrique en Exilus la vie et puis
aussi vous intéresser comme Bernard et
Lévy d'ailleurs au guerre oubliés la
cire alléonne tout toutes ces guerres
finalement on parle jamais
on a la tragédie de de moi et une fois
que c'est passé
on oublie que les gens sont toujours
dans la misère et que les problèmes sont
pas réglés mais il faut pas oublier
qu'il une fois qu'il ne voit plus à la
télévision il faut pas penser que tout
est réglé alors cette fille de pasteur
vous croyez et vous dites je crois en
quelque chose mais pas forcément en la
religion parce que les idées des grands
penseurs ont trop souvent été déformés
par leur disciples les croyez en quoi
alors
je crois qu'il nous être humain nous
sommes là pour pour une raison nous
sommes nés pour une bonne raison et mais
nous ne sont pas seuls
nous sommes pas seuls je crois que en
tout cas moi je ne sens pas seul et
je crois que je fais partie de quelque
chose qui est qui est grand qui est
immense je crois en nous je crois en
dans ce qui est bon en nous mais il faut
travailler ça c'est pas facile merci et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu